Hallo miteinander,
es freut mich sehr,
dass mein Film "Jung und bekifft"
so rege geschaut wird
und auf YouTube
viel kommentiert wird.
Es sind unglaublich
viele Kommentare eingegangen.
Grösstenteils
sind es sehr faire Kommentare,
das freute uns sehr.
Andrea Förtsch schreibt:
Ich bin keine Psychiaterin
und keine Expertin
auf dem Gebiet Cannabis
und Cannabiskonsum.
Ich habe mir einiges an Wissen
angeeignet.
Zur Depersonalisierung
würde ich sagen ...
Um das Wort Depersonalisierung
zu verstehen:
Man ist ausserhalb seiner Person,
so fühlt es sich an.
Man nimmt die Realität
wie eine andere Person war.
So hat es Till im Film beschrieben.
Damit man zu einem Psychiater geht
und Hilfe in Anspruch nimmt,
braucht es
einen gewissen Leidensdruck.
Das ist bei den Jugendlichen
in meinem Film der Fall.
Erst, wenn sie merken,
dass sie nicht mehr weiterkommen,
dass sie überfordert sind,
haben sie
Hilfe in Anspruch genommen.
Zum Vorwurf,
der Film gehe zu wenig in die Tiefe:
Es ist wahnsinnig schwierig,
alle Facetten des Thema Cannabis
zu berücksichtigen.
Eigentlich unmöglich.
Ich habe mich deshalb entschieden,
mich auf die Jugendlichen
zu fokussieren.
Bei meiner Recherche merkte ich,
dass sie viel zu wenig
zu Wort kommen.
Man schreibt über sie,
man redet über sie,
aber sie selbst haben keine Stimme
bei diesem Thema.
Weil ich so tolle Jugendliche fand,
entschied ich mich,
ihnen das Wort zu geben.
Zu sagen, wie sie dazu kamen,
wie sie sich fühlten,
wie sie ihre Erlebnisse
rückblickend anschauen.
Hier sind wir in die Tiefe gegangen.
Vielleicht hätte es noch mehr
"normale" Jugendliche geben können.
Die Basler und die Berner Community,
die Freunde
der einzelnen Protagonisten.
Im Film
geht es nicht darum, zu zeigen,
dass kiffen gut und problemlos ist
und es alle machen.
Viele machen es.
Aber vielleicht mit etwas zu wenig
Wissen, was alles passieren kann.
Deshalb haben wir diese Schwerpunkte
gelegt und keine anderen.
Sonja Sönnelii schreibt:
Das stimmt,
ich finde es aussergewöhnlich.
Die Jugendlichen,
die mitgemacht haben,
haben unglaublich mutig und frei
ihre Geschichten erzählt.
Sie äusserten die Hoffnung,
dass andere Jugendliche
das so wahrnehmen
und ihnen zuhören und
von ihren Erfahrungen profitieren.
Vielleicht auch, dass Erwachsene
von den Erfahrungen der Jugendlichen
profitieren können und einen
Einblick in diese Welt bekommen.
Ein ganz grosses Kompliment
an meine Protagonisten.
Die Community stellte die Frage,
weshalb wir nur Leute zeigen,
die durch den Konsum
Probleme bekamen.
Slimo Beatz:
Warum habt ihr nur Leute
mit Problemen genommen?
Ich kiffe seit zehn Jahren und hatte
bisher nur positive Erlebnisse.
Im Off-Text sage ich:
Cannabis ist ein Jugendphänomen
und kein Jugendproblem.
Bei meiner Recherche zeigte sich,
dass auch
gut informierte Jugendliche
nicht gut genug informiert sind,
dass sie Probleme ausklammern.
Sie wissen,
dass es Psychosen auslösen könnte,
aber sie wollen es nicht hören -
sie wollen sich dem Rausch hingeben.
Dafür wollten wir sensibilisieren.
Sir Viper schreibt:
Ich sehe das nicht ganz so.
An mehreren Stellen im Film
sagen die Jugendlichen,
wie einfach es für sie war und ist,
an Gras zu kommen.
Einfacher, als Alkohol zu bekommen.
Der Gesetzgeber
verfolgt den illegalen Stoff,
sie ziehen den Stoff ein,
sie sprechen Bussen aus.
Trotzdem kommen die Jugendlichen
unglaublich einfach an Gras.
Das wollten wir aufzeigen.
Ich verstehe den Film
als Diskussionsbeitrag.
Ob der Stoff legalisiert werden soll
oder nicht,
dazu beziehen wir keine Position.
Das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe.
Lukas Patrik Gysel schreibt:
Herr Gysel, ich freue mich,
dass Sie das zu ihren Kindern haben.
Danke, dass Sie das so schreiben.
Wie gesagt, wir wollten uns
auf die Jugendlichen fokussieren,
wir wollten ihnen eine Stimme geben.
Stellvertretend für Eltern
steht Tills Mutter.
Sie zeigt sehr gut auf,
wie schwierig es ist,
bei diesem Thema auf
die Jugendlichen Einfluss zu nehmen.
Man kann sie sensibilisieren,
informieren.
Letztlich fangen die Jugendlichen
an zu kiffen - wenn sie es tun -
in einem Lebensabschnitt, in dem
die Eltern den Einfluss verlieren.
Da können die Eltern
noch so viel mit ihnen reden.
Es ist nicht gesagt,
dass sie es verhindern können.
Die Peergroup wird immer wichtiger.
Der Drang, etwas auszuprobieren,
ist ebenfalls da.
Kneister Meister schreibt:
Vorher rauchte Till
Cannabis mit einem hohen THC-Gehalt.
Das hat eine berauschende Wirkung.
Seither raucht er höchstens noch -
wenn überhaupt - CBD.
CBD hat einen
sehr geringen THC-Gehalt.
Deshalb ist es legal.
Ab 18 kann man es
an jedem Kiosk kaufen.
Vielen Dank, das war's fürs Erste.
Ich habe mich gefreut, dass ihr
so aktiv mitdiskutiert habt.
Das könnt ihr weiterhin gerne tun.
Ihr könnt Fragen
in den Chat schreiben.
Wir beobachten und beantworten sie.
Wenn ihr ein Thema habt,
von dem ihr findet,
dass wir es unbedingt bearbeiten
sollten, schreibt auch das.
Ihr könnt unseren Kanal abonnieren,
dann wisst ihr,
welche Dokumentationen gerade in
Arbeit sind und publiziert werden.